my name is Nicola raka cutter I'm an
independent filmmaker from Chile and I
knew pretty early on that I wanted to
like tell stories hopefully make movies
I was like 13 I guess then I went
through high school and everything and
then iced I went to a pretty humble
university and being at my old
University I admire where I i studied
cinema it's like a film school and I had
pretty good teachers like and
screenwriter teachers and art history
teachers and cinema history teachers who
taught you more of the craft and
appreciate their the art itself and
during my university days I made a
couple of short films and I ended up my
career with a very like ambitious
project who was a very big movie about a
real life case happen here in Tunis of
some psychopaths and I actually shot
like 20 minutes of that movie and turn
it into a some kind of teaser and went
to like the contest the government has
to finance films and I didn't get it I
guess that was good because it was a
really big movie for me to take I was 22
I was really young but I got the
opportunity to work with with great
talents like big talented actors and I
had a great script and that kind of
opened up some something for me then
when I finished the University I went on
to make an independent short film which
I did and went to a couple of festivals
and get a got a few a world and a year
after that I set out to make my first
feature I I went to a lower scale of
feature
and in the summer of 2013 I shot it
it's called distance distance eeeh
and I premiered it in 2015 in the
meantime while I was in post-production
of that film I switch cities and I came
to Santiago which is the capital of
Chile and started a job at a university
in a department where I was in charge of
like making original content where I
developed a series of micro
documentaries and it has 10 set 10
episodes it's about different crafts
that are losing with time like
shoemakers and bicycle makers and stuff
like that and then I made another
project that consisted in make driving
like a few independent musicians from
Chile a couple of them songs some some
from theirs and I gave them to
illustrators who painted like a picture
of the song in a in a canvas and that
became like a series of music videos
that was along with the exposition like
a museum exposition of the of the the
art itself and then I switched jobs and
now I'm the director of like video
content in in local radios big local
radius from Chile where I like direct
commercials and and make projects and
recently we we premiered a documentary
about life music I guess that the
current and always issue about
independent filmmaker is like making the
time to actually do the work to pull out
your own projects it's hard when you
have a day job lucky for me my day job
also consists on on having a cab
hand and trying to develop stories so
I'm not that away from the craft itself
but it's still an issue like to make
time to get home and actually sit down
and trying to get something written down
for our project that you're trying to
pull off on your own and and like don't
try and not to let the day-to-day issues
that work I mean family love life or
whatever can come up too to get in the
way of what you're trying to do because
you actually have to be in a very
peaceful or sort of peaceful mindset in
order to to actually get something done
it's really easy to start
procrastinating in and having a lot of
self-doubt and and mainly issues with
oneself like I'm not good enough for why
am I going to do this if I'm if probably
gonna turn out worse than the previous
thing that I did which didn't actually
turn out bad but one it's always it's
its own critic I think that the best way
that you can deal with with such issues
is this is actually like be super
headstrong and and trying not to be the
perfectionist that in my case I'm always
trying to achieve you know I'm a real
perfectionist so it's kind of hard when
you are halfway through a project and
you realize that it's not what your unit
had in your mind and you don't find it
perfect and don't put it aside it's
actually the work itself that you need
to keep doing so I guess that the way
I'm trying to deal with these issues is
like I'm trying to do it no matter what
no matter what the outcome is I mean
even if I'm young I know a lot of young
filmmakers out there that you have to
keep doing the work you know you can
achieve like service like an amount of
of greatness in the in the craft if you
don't
we do it so I guess that you always keep
on learning while you're doing so it's
really important to just push through it
and keep doing no matter what don't
think about what's coming next you know
like the once you get a job done and you
put it out there it's up to public
opinion and public opinion sometimes can
suck but sometimes it doesn't but that
doesn't mean that it had to have to
condemn the way you do things you just
have to keep on doing them
I think what's actually like paralyzing
in some way is fear first of all fear of
failure but you can't even begin to fail
if you don't try so I guess that the
hardest thing for me to do is to be that
headstrong and just keep on doing it no
matter what just sit down and and I
don't know finish a screenplay even
though if it's not gonna get shot just
do it maybe have like 10 20 screenplays
locked in a drawer until they're gonna
be just probably one could be a short
film could be a documentary could be
anything but one that will get shot and
then eventually is gonna come up with
another different issues but you just
have to finish every project that you
set your mind to do I think that's
really important because frustration is
even worse when you set out to start
something and you don't finish it I
don't know that there's any film makers
out there that tend to deal with the
same issues that I do
and I wonder what do we do - I don't
know overcome fear and keep pushing
through